es ist ein langer weg in die abgelegenen
ecken der karoo jener wundervollen aber
kargen landschaft in südafrika der trotz
der hilfsorganisation gift auf beginners
wird sehnlichst erwartet ein parkplatz
als ort der hoffnung denn längst
herrscht hunger hier in der provinz
eastern cape
erst kam die schlimmste dürre seit 50
jahren dann kam cupid 19
tausende wie die saison kam arbeitete
rossi und kdc koi stehen am abgrund
wissen morgens oft nicht was ihre kinder
abends essen sollen
wir finden wegen des lockouts einfach
keine jobs deswegen kommen wir hierher
um die lebensmittelrationen abzuholen
mais reis nudeln wohnen dosen fischte
und satz 15 familien bekommen an diesem
tag ein paket zum überleben
[Musik]
chorin conradi ist die verantwortliche
für die region kaum eine gegend die
nicht um hilfe bittet sagt sie es fehlt
an jobs weil die korona bedingt
schwierige wirtschaftslage auf den
farmen hier zu schaffen macht
der preis um die hilferufe aus den
verschiedenen städten sind sehr ernst
wir bekommen andauernd anrufe menschen
unter tränen sagen bitte helft uns wir
haben hunger
kinder können nicht essen yasni und
artistik hoffen dass die ration sie und
ihre vier kinder wenigstens über den
nächsten monat bringt völlige
verzweiflung die pandemie trifft die
ärmsten hat ausgerechnet in südafrika
das seit dem ende der apartheid vor 26
jahren mit den gräben zwischen arm und
reich kämpften das land am kap der guten
hoffnung wurde von der pandemie so
schwer getroffen wie kein anderes in
afrika dabei wurde früh einer der
härtesten lockt das weltweit verhängt
die folge die wirtschaft schrumpft bis
zu drei millionen menschen könnten ihre
jobs verlieren
mittlerweile wurden die maßnahmen
gelockert aber viele unternehmen und
geschäfte kämpfen ums überleben
auch viele aus der mittelschicht
südafrikas fühlen sich bedroht sie kussa
balala ist ein selfmade mann aus soweto
johannesburg berühmtesten township
während der apartheid wuchs er hier in
ärmlichen verhältnissen auf eröffnete
ein restaurant hatte es geschafft
aber der lange lockt dann und die folgen
könnten ihn nun in die knie zwingen
sonntag sollten wir um diese zeit in der
küche eigentlich sehr beschäftigt sein
aber das sind wir nicht einfach weil die
gäste nur vereinzelt kommen und nicht
mehr so wie früher
dabei ist sein laden eigentlich eine
goldgrube
er liegt direkt an der bekannten will ak
si street wo sich normalerweise die
touristen drängeln und die menschen aus
soweto flanieren nelson mandelas altes
wohnhaus ist der anziehungspunkt derzeit
aber geht fast gar nichts mehr
ausländische besucher können ohnehin
nicht einreisen aber auch viele
einheimische halten ihr geld zusammen
denn es geht vielen die den angestellten
concia balala
die derzeit nur einen teil ihres gehalts
bekommen wenn mittlere unternehmen die
seines pleitegingen könnte dass die
südafrikanische gesellschaft schwer
erschüttern glaubt der 61-jährige der
graben wird riesig werden du wirst
entweder superreich oder super arm sein
es wird keine mittelschicht mehr geben
wegen dieser situation auch er hat angst
vor dem abstieg
dabei liegt es gerade so gut der
restaurantbesitzer zeigt uns das haus
das eigentlich längst das neue heim
seiner familie sein sollte aber wegen
des corona lockt downs musste er die
umbauarbeiten einstellen nun fehlt ihm
das geld zum weitermachen
das bedroht nicht nur meinen
lebensunterhalt sondern auch den meiner
kinder
ich mache das für meine familie
womöglich kann ich das haus nicht
fertigstellen und muss es verkaufen
zibuschka balala macht sich sorgen ob er
auch zukünftig die gute privatschule für
seine söhne bezahlen kann
aber es ist nicht nur die
wirtschaftliche lage seine frau und er
haben familienangehörige und enge
freunde durch ko mit 9 10 verloren
wir haben ende mai unsere mutter
verloren und danach drei onkel meine
beste freundin und andere freunde
es sind so viele es sind bislang
mindestens zehn personen die mir nahe
standen
das bringt dich an einen punkt an dem du
wie betäubt ist auch hier gibt es viele
kroner fälle aber für menschen wie hosni
und cuddy seco geht es oft mehr um das
tägliche überleben
die lebensmittelrationen die sie
bekommen haben ist zumindest eine kleine
erleichterung im täglichen kampf den
alltag zu schaffen vor allem das
nötigste für die kinder zu organisieren
ich möchte meine tränen nicht vor den
kindern zeigen das würde mir weh tun
sie sollen mich nicht zu sehen wie
würden sich meine kinder dabei fühlen
zumindest sinken mittlerweile die
fallzahlen in südafrika aber die
pandemie ist damit noch lange nicht
vorbei und die langfristigen folgen
nicht absehbar